you know I have to pee right now I got a
I got to do some urine but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna you ever do that you got
you got a do you know you got it you
just ride that full bag baby you know
I'm dissing I'm just like a I mean I
should be surfing right now I got you
know I'm basically I'm like whatever
that surfer guy's name is just riding
that yellow right now I'm on dude I am
full my body is full right now of urine
but I'm not gonna pee I'm gonna ride
that bag and and stay in the pocket and
do my work and do this episode right
here I'm gonna tough it out the two I am
today I'm somebody that's gonna tough it
out
[Music]
celebrate live
cellophane is
[Music]
celebrate dark days celebrate all your
things our ways I'm not even sure what
they say in it but that is celebrate by
Spencer Jacob growl who is a musician
and he lent us that song and and that's
a real happening tune and music is neat
in music neat because it's like a you
know it's something that gets into your
body it's almost like ants music is like
ants and they crawl in the air and some
time to answer a real chill they crawl
slow and they vibin and they from
Jamaica and you they smoking that Gangi
died they got them big horse leg hitters
them giants you know what I'm saying
they got them them big giants but now
other times you'll get them those ants
and they they're climbing in here any of
sound holes in the ears and they looking
at you know they flying fast and they
stand busy then big body then big dogs
inside of you and that's what sound is
sound is just it's just really just a
ghost that has a lot of noise in it and
it just just gets right into your head
it makes you feel some type of way who
school school is back for a lot of
families right now it's coming back this
is the big weekend and thank you for
checking in this is the big last weekend
before school memmer remember the summer
was long you had summer camp and you
might have went through a little bit of
her buddy you know what one day you wake
up in your legs a little bit
longer or you got a little bit of hair
on your kneecaps or you got you know
maybe you get a little titty or
something you wake up in the morning and
you got a little kitty and you fell
asleep uh Sans Conte you know without
tit but you wake up in the morning and
your shirt got a little bitter you know
some of your fat is kind of meeting up
around your nipple like they smoking a
giant like your nipple was like a brown
junk and some of your fat cells kind of
met up around it to hit to get that hit
or baby and that is a tit that's how at
it starts and men we don't get them some
guys we've had we had a fella that got
some wild tits from Tennessee uh last
year and he got tattoos on him and
everything in but a lot of men don't get
up don't get titty you know a lot of men
don't get titty but it is school time
dude I went out when school was coming
and he got in that last week and summer
was wrapping up like about a week before
I would I would set my clothes out on my
bed I knew what I was wearing mom had
got us two outfits one of them you know
usually has some Shabo jeans or
something and maybe it a VAR net t-shirt
or something nice
I had my Eastlands them low top Eastland
hitters baby them foot boats baby them
shoes
and I get them headers and lay them out
I later pants out I'd even roll the pant
legs up a little like I was as if my
body was on the ground I would lay my
whole outfit on the ground and look at
that [ __ ] and say damn that boy he
looks and he's gonna look nice
and then I'd have my outfit I'd have it
all and man school came fast man and you
had your new clothes do it in our first
day of school I get my hair fixed up I
put everything in my hair do I shampoo
it do i conditioner it then I put a
little damn you know I put some musk
powder in it I put a little gel I put a
little foam I put a little more in it I
do it all I put some baby powder and the
size boy case the ladies come a-knockin
this head smell is rocking because look
a lot of ladies they want a baby that's
genetic if you throw a baby up in the
air and it's little enough a lot of
ladies will catch it right there in that
fridge in their veggetti but they'll
catch it in that that vid you know that
vagina net boy they'll just do it I do a
headstand and catch that BAM beem
because the ladies want that BB they
want it dude if you if you put a LIF you
put a baby on roller skates and send it
by a couple ladies they're gonna follow
it
and that's 100% science or so you know
that's there's a lot of you got to know
what's up so that's the thing if you put
a little baby powder in your hair that's
the bait and switch they they smell that
baby and then BAM they get that man you
feel me
they get you and that's what it was on
for my from everything went in my hair
first day of school
dude I do everything to get the ladies
to come around looking at that poivre
baby looking at that hitter baby that
looking at that freaking crisper I was a
crisper Potamus you feel me
and everything went in mine had a little
bit of Cologne I'd even take a hit off
that cologne at the thing you know
because some of that got Ralph Lauren
they used to have that Ralph Lauren
Cologne and that [ __ ] was probably about
nine proof and I'd put a little bit I
pour you know pour drop in each year and
then just get that get a little head in
myself boy you drink enough cologne your
breath will smell good for damn at least
two seasons you know come winter you
just you just easing off that positive
scent you'd have in you and man that
first day you I my hair had it all my
hair had it Oh everything was in there I
put all of just trying to put a little
ketchup behind my ears anything to get
the ladies to look over it Popeye and it
was from him in the first day of school
he showed up and no matter what I had on
the outside but you were all excited
who's doing what who's got a beard who's
pregnant who failed who didn't fail who
moved away all Dame
Leonard moved away who was Leonard I
didn't even [ __ ] know him boy by
Leonard somebody did this somebody did
something and you came back to school
and you found out all dang Patrick went
to Texas how was it you know little wah
Jennifer she caught her oh she caught a
couple charges she was escorting outside
'adam a MP you're like damn sorry
Jennifer and what else little love ldren
got his oh he got corn road damn love
ldren that [ __ ] looks tasty everybody
brought the tales from their summer back
you know somebody somebody had a nice
shirt they went to Florida memmer net
Florida you see they had this sure safe
Florida
and that was the real hit or somebody
that went to Florida like damn I mean
Florida was our moon you know Florida
was really our moon
but huh there was no it was so exciting
but then also was so nervous because
every year that first day of school was
like oh Cara the girl's gonna like me
this year you know what am I just gonna
be too am I gonna be as any girl gonna
look at me as Emma you know what's my
vibe gonna be Who am I and some time I
you know I come to school and I had bad
acne and acne is just I mean your dick
is so wiling and yet when you're young
your dick is just such an animals trying
to climb out of your head from the
inside of you I mean while you're laying
there at night your dick will run up
through your neck up to your face and
try to jump out of your pores and your
pores get all bruised from the inside
and that's acne and it shows on the
outside and they got a little bit of
bust and some of them got a little bit
of bus because that's I mean you're just
yeah your hormones is so vibrant your
hormones they thought you know they they
Wilin and they try you in you know and
you dick just scooting around inside of
you trying to bust out of your face at
night and leaving little divots and
stuff and that's acne and that's another
thing if you showed up with acne at
school member well she broke my heart
dude coming to school you had a huge zit
on you
that thing was heavy some dude I had
acne so bad one time I remember having
one said it was kind of heavy on the
side of my face like damn I couldn't
even I had to have one of my buddies
kind of just pull down on my other ear
you know just to keep my head straight
because I had that heavy Zee baby that
big city that baked ziti on my side I
was fully Italian that
you know that little bust lump that acne
that that things trying to cuz you were
just so hard a member remember how horny
you were as a boy as a child remember a
new da some kid died I remember we went
to his funeral he was erect in a coffin
like damn damn Wallis's he got that
death bust enemy trying to bust from
beyond it was different different time
but I remembered and I know a lot of
your parents have your kids going back
to school and just uh my thoughts are
with you because I know it's it's an
exciting time and you guys are looking
for a break it's probably been a long
summer out there and I remember my mom
it was risky every day she would leave
the house and who knows that that thing
was gonna be standing when she got home
you
just a risk she just left a couple dang
risk uh Potamus is just milling around
inside of the zoo that was our home when
she went to work in the summertime
what's going on my family was in town
this past weekend my family came out
here
and it was cool you know we went to
Disneyland and and it was hectic and
chaotic but it was nice you know it was
nice to my mother came my brother and my
sister came they brought their children
five total children beautiful children
you know and my family is lucky to uh
you know have five able-bodied children
that are able to you know see and and
experience and feel and be creative and
and laugh and just you know we're really
fortunate that the you know that we have
a lot of health in our family and um and
it was nice you know my mom was here and
and it was nice it was the first time
we'd all ever done something like that
all together rented a house got a nice
air B&B and we stayed there together and
it was a little tough for me because
I've been dealing with a lot of stress
and you know sometime I just have to be
by myself I just can't you know honestly
I was having trouble does being grateful
and I feel a little sad some
because sometimes I go into an
experience and I want it to be a certain
way you know I want you know I want
though you know I want to you know I
know my family's coming so I think oh
I'm gonna be up and Adam every morning
I'm gonna be active and you know I'm
gonna help out as much as I can and I'm
gonna just keep a positive attitude and
this and that and and then you know the
weekend that finally the week comes
they're coming in town and I've been
having to work a lot and just been
overwhelmed and you know not aa I was
good you know I was a good son I was a
good uncle I was a good brother but it's
never I guess sometimes I would just
have too much expectations you know and
it almost prevents me from enjoying
stuff sometimes because my mind is
already created you know such a cliff
that I can't the odds of me being on
that cliff or or being it that my mom
you know my mind has created such a
level that the that the odds of me the
amount of the reality of the experience
once it comes being at that level are
probably very slim you know I have this
imagination or this expectation in my
head that oh everything is gonna be like
this and then the truth comes and look
the kids they their kids one of them you
know they're wiling out and they're
having fun and they're in a new place
and there's a swimming pool and they're
they're being kids and you know the
truth is my mom's driving me nuts half
the time and so you know when the truth
is I know sometimes I'm probably driving
people nuts so I take myself out I go
put myself in a bedroom for a little bit
by myself so I don't bother anybody
sometimes I it's a I got a babysit
myself you know and the reality is we
had a great time it was fun you know we
worked as a team
you know somebody would cook breakfast
and I was you know what did I do I did
how did I contribute I played with the
kids
you know I made sure all the
audio/visual stuff if we were watching a
movie or the kids wanted to watch they
had this cool little projector outside
that would be on the wall so the kids
could watch TV outside and that was
really cool that's one nice thing about
California the weather they got outside
projector sometimes and so you know and
so I helped with that hmm what else I
was good you know I contributed as much
as I could I was good at Disney I kept
things move and I stayed positive you
know I didn't I didn't be greedy at all
if it came to finances I you know I over
contributed or contributed as much as I
could afford so so in the truth is we
had a great time the thing for me was
just my expectations I don't know I
build these crazy expectations that life
is never gonna live up to because it's
life and there's variables and there's
just so I got to manage my expectations
sometimes you know but I'll live and
learn man you know I'll live and learn
all the time and that's all we do we
ain't winning this deal and I'm saying
we're all getting second place
nobody's getting duween getting first
bro I mean I'm not getting first man you
know progress not perfection and and I
know if I go to you know I need to go to
some more AAA meetings and I've been you
know neglecting my program and and I
know if I do that and then I'll get rid
of a lot of the stress that I have
inside of me because I'm living life you
know I'm I'm trying to just I'm every
it's all my own will I want everything
and I got to recognize that the world is
gonna be what its gonna be and I can't
a lot of expectations you know not
further from the whole world I can
expect things out of myself but I can't
be combative with the way the world is
or how other people artists it's just
I'll lose every time
so so I'm trying to find a little more
gratitude man and and a man and my heart
goes out I was saying you know these
news stories with these shootings and my
heart goes out to the people in those
cities and the people that are affected
by those things and you know and my
heart goes out to them what else is
going on yeah we had a nice time and I
hate to brush over the you know the
family visit but we went to Disneyland
and my thing is my thing about Disney
dude I like watching I love seeing Asian
people eat big things and I used to
watch it on the internet they used to
have a good series out there on the
YouTube about it was a lot of Chinese
and kind of you know kind of Miko's kind
of many Koreans eating uh big pieces of
pound cake and you could see them wonder
you know and it's beautiful because you
know Asians are probably one of the top
easily top four ethnicities are five and
when you see them they're so docile and
they're so and this is a I'm talking to
some of the newer generation it's more
active you know you got more you know
you got a lot more you know they got a
lot more gun powder in them some of the
you know kind of more recent Asians but
I'm talking you go back a generation you
got a lot of DA's bore them docile
Asians and man watching one of them just
kind of just
just you know just navigate a big piece
of pound cake or a big cotton candy with
that small that small Huffer they got
that small mouth and god it's beautiful
it's beautiful it's like watching nature
work and watching God work and so that's
one thing I love about Disneyland is
seeing just just what I mean you and you
got to pay attention there's not a sign
that says hey hey buddy over here look
at the Lord work over here you got up
you got to navigate and see what's going
on and sometimes on a park bench just
off you you know outside here you got to
kind of go like that and they'll see
you'll see a park bench and I'll have
two beautiful ASEAN baby Asians
beautiful and they are and they're a
beautiful culture and you'll see them
you know one on what it'd be like a big
turkey leg and one of them with uh a big
cotton candy and me it seems like
they're whispering to it but they're
ingesting it it's beautiful I mean it's
really it's something that's you know
I'm surprised it's not in more travel
guides but I love that I love that about
Disneyland and just everybody having
everybody having fun and and we enjoyed
it in that we made the most of it and
the kid you know the kids are crying and
a fight and and somebody drank a bunch
of bubbles but that's life that's life
and I got to realize that I'm grateful
to be in it and I am and I am you know
and I think I've just been struggling a
lot with just my gratitude and just
remembering to be grateful because my
life is good man I'm healthy you know
I'm able to breathe you know I have a
career that I want you know I have
people that love me you know I
have a mother that's alive I can talk to
I have a brother that I know cares about
me till the end of the world you know I
have I have the ability to love others I
have legs that work you know so I can be
I can help others you know I can take
action I have a voice I can speak I have
dreams and I have the ability to take
action on some of them you know and uh
you know I just have a lot of blessings
and I just I hate when i forget that
because it leaves me in a space where I
am I don't know I just
myself and I'm not that I don't hate
myself but I don't I just
I've lived in gratitude before and man
it is a good place to be you know
because when you're grateful you're not
alone and you're not in judgment that's
the thing I just hate me in judgmental I
hate it
and it's tough because I'm a comedian
and there's part of that in there but
there's I hate it when you know III
don't know everything's gonna be okay
I'm just gonna work I'm gonna do a
little bit better being in gratitude and
I'm thankful for you guys I'm thankful
you know we got sold-out shows this week
in Sacramento I think Las Vegas is
almost sold out for this weekend and
they say that that rarely happens
because it's a you know Las Vegas is a
destination city but I'll be in
Sacramento on the eighth and ninth of
this week and then on the tenth Saturday
night I'll be in Las Vegas so you guys
can come out Theo von comm slash tour
also coming up shows in Brea Biloxi
Scotland Dublin Oslo Stockholm London
Manchester and Amsterdam we just added
another show in Sayreville New Jersey on
October 3rd and there's just there's a
lot of shows theof on.com slash tour t
oh you are well I'll tell you this if
you like sex and I know people do
because sometime if you put your ear up
to the wind you could hear people [ __ ]
bra in the distance and if you like sex
then you will love blue chew blue cube
baby blue - blue chew a blue chew it's
almost like somebody sneeze like but you
but it's not it's erection blue to
offers men a performance enhancement for
the bedroom or kitchen boy [ __ ] where
you want to that's what I see
would you like to last longer and go
extra rounds I wouldn't but I'm not you
at blue ChiCom you can get the first
chewables with the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
chewables can work faster than pills up
to twice as fast but the chewables from
blue qu can be taken on a full or empty
stomach first of all I think the type of
guy that's gonna be doing sex on a full
stomach boy are you crazy are you crazy
what you think I'm gonna have to uh two
pork chops and then sprout a t-bone hell
no I [ __ ] on empty I'm that bad boy I
[ __ ] on empty Sun and even masturbate I
don't even masturbate on a full stomach
that's what Harley what year is it 1930
me come on guys hello blue choo ships
directly to your door in discrete
packaging the chewables from blue to
calm are prescribed
online by a doctor and made in the USA
no more does crazy wild [ __ ] get the
local blue Qi gives you confidence in
bed every time you and your partner will
love it chew it and do it here's a great
deal for you guys visit blue chew BL you
eche w.com and get your first order free
when you use promo code th EO just pay
$5 shipping that's BL to you e CH e
w.com
and use promo code th e oh the online
physician consult is free so it's
cheaper then there's other two fancy
pills you hear about it takes a few
minutes blue chew gum use promo code
Theo and look you you know I've been
through a I've had all the erectile
problems I mean I've done you know dude
I remember about five years I didn't
have an erection so if you saw me you'd
be like damn that guy just got a lot of
loose skin around as kind of a near as
nuts and that was my wiener but not
anymore if I need to get
if I need to get that that Tony Gwynn
then I throw that blue Chewie I throw it
in my gums boy so let's get to a couple
calls here that came in the hotline as
always is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and if you're
struggling with something you know when
you need somebody to reach out to or
something like that you can hit the
hotline and we listen to every call that
comes in and thank you for being a part
of this past weekend in this experience
gang always gang man yeah this is angel
and Tulsa Oklahoma actually got the
pleasure to meet you you helped my
family out well we had a great loss Oh
angel I do remember that actually thank
you guys for coming out a believer I
want to say hold on I have my booklet
here you usually have some of that stuff
written down but I believe your mother
had passed away let's hear more and I
was listening to the podcast last night
and I've been thinking about it and you
know don't stop being a bright light
just because somebody's you know having
a bad day we don't know what that woman
was going through but I'm a single mom
with three boys and you know I would
never treat anybody like that that some
people just weren't raised right and
some people just don't have that God
spark to say hey I'm doing somebody
wrong you know we're lucky that we have
that kind of spirit in us and you know I
work with people daily they were in
hospice and listen to your podcast and
it just always brings like an uplifting
spirit and what you do for single moms
is just amazing so don't let this one
nasty lady who is probably having a
nasty day we're in your spirit we love
you Gang Gang Gang Gang
thank you for the call angel I
appreciate that yeah and I know you're
talking about last week with the you
know dad the single mom came out to San
Francisco
and she really really [ __ ] the bed and
you know what I think I had expectations
you know I think I had you know I wanted
it to go a certain way
and there's there's things I can't
control though you're right you know and
I felt a little bad about I thought a
little bit about it like part of me is
like you know I don't know what that
lady you know you can't make people do
anything you know and I'm sure there's
been times in my life when people tried
to help me and I [ __ ] on them or I
didn't do you know I could have done
better I did I remember some people you
know they let me come live with them
when I was a child and the neighbors was
lesbians and I would drive through the
yard in the morning in a 1984 Ford
Escort and pour vodka out the window for
no real reason and and it wasn't because
they were lesbians they happen to be
lesbians and their yard happen to be
across the street but I'm sure when
those people open their doors to me they
weren't thinking oh yeah just boy gonna
go hot wheeling you know through these
munchers [ __ ] hedges you feel me so
yeah we all do stuff but yeah you're
right I proceeded saying that and yeah I
just you know I'm gonna limit my
expectations and or try to and do and do
what I can and we do what we can I think
part of it is yeah it's like we got a
group we do some good we're trying to do
a little bit of good and most of the
time we succeed I mean out there in
Tulsa too you know we had to to single
moms came out to Cain's Ballroom over
there and boy that was a show we put it
on them and God bless all the single
mothers getting their children ready for
school coming up on this week I know you
are you need a break and bless you young
lady for working in hospice you know
you're right there on the front lines of
uh of life and death and that's you know
my brother his wife's grandmother passed
away last week and she was a beautiful
woman man and she always made me feel
good every time I saw Avis that was her
name
mama Avis and she always made me feel
good and I know she was in hospice right
before she passed and and I know you
guys are right there and it takes a
special person to to do that work and so
thank you very much for doing that
angel let's take some other calls that
came in ninety five six six four nine
five zero three schools almost back dude
I wouldn't know man here's the tough
thing first of all spending time with my
nieces and nephews this past weekend set
me back a couple years I want to have
children man they are so energetic and
their parents have to be so patient and
what if you're kidding even smart and
you got to get him ready for school you
you know you spending one hundred and
thirty dollars getting them a bunch of
you know some new zapatos for la escuela
and you know he ain't even [ __ ] smart
that's got to be crazy
you know you sending a little freaking
uh you know little um little mark or
little Darius our little Hector you got
him one hundred and thirty dollars you
got him a new pencil pouch and you
hugging him and saying oh yeah you're
gonna have fun this year buddy then you
close the door and go to your room
you're like damn he my child is he's
dumbest [ __ ] man he'll be lucky to get
through this [ __ ] I gotta because he do
parents must have to pretend so much huh
that's so fascinating man you giving him
two dollars for lunch knowing he's just
gonna be fueling up to go back to a
class that he ain't even gotta do well
man is crazy man shoutout to all the
parents out there you guys are warriors
you guys are warriors I witness so many
of y'all and our Disneyland this weekend
working the frontlines of raising
children and it was pretty beautiful man
to see in the families all just doing
the best they
to make it a nice experience for their
kids and the sacrifice and it's
beautiful you know it's beautiful and my
mother took my brother and I there when
I was young and and I'm sure she
probably had to sacrifice a lot to do
that and so it was nice - it was nice to
have that memory while I was there this
weekend let's take another call I was it
going Theo this is will from Burlington
Vermont
what's up will from Burlington and
Burlington ah it's um form on I've
always wanted to go and my luggage went
once I uh
Southwest Airlines messed my luggage up
and sent it over there to you guys and I
don't know what happened to it [ __ ]
somebody probably wearing some of my
[ __ ] right now I did have a nice
crewneck sweatshirt that I really it was
kind of heather gray or something and it
said boys will be boys on the back so if
anybody sees anybody wearing it over
there outside of I think it was
Manchester Vermont maybe or something I
don't know I don't know at all actually
let's hear more I just listened to your
podcast where you put that guy on blast
for recommending a single mom that
wasn't didn't really behave that well
and I thought that was kind of messed up
for you to do that I'm a huge fan but I
mean that guy I mean that guy probably
really looks up to you and and I mean
you know he was just trying to do
something nice for somebody who he
thought was fine and and you know it
turns out obviously that she may have
been kind of an alcoholic or something
along those lines but I mean he
obviously didn't know that and I just
feel like you just kind of put him on
blast you called him during his lunch
break and he kind of took out your anger
on him and I don't know I didn't like
that I mean that being said it was that
was it was pretty entertaining but I
mean he's he you know you're probably
one of his role models I think you
should have directed that anger towards
the woman she really she really
screwed up but oh well appreciated man I
appreciate the call um yeah you know I
felt bad about that when we got to the
end of the episode I was driving home
and I was thinking man I felt like I
forgot something
you ever know that you might be
somewhere you forget something maybe you
had your but you you had a campout or
something
you drive halfway home you realize you
know man you pat in your pockets you're
like damn I left my you know maybe a
Playboy magazine or a hustler or a club
one of them you know a little bit of
jerk off kind of no you know novellas
really or magazines something you could
jerk around to pictures mostly you know
titties and everything but yeah man I
agree with you I felt like I forgot
something and I felt like yeah I took my
anger out on that guy you know I was
angry I was angry man and I can be angry
you know sometimes I can be nice and
sometimes I can be angry I can be both
of those people I can be somebody who is
who is a loving person and also somebody
who overreact sometimes and doesn't
manage things well you know I'm a
I am a we all are we all are were more
than one thing and that's a good point
man and that lady could be more than one
thing you know she could be a couple of
things now also if she's four things
three of those things could be a
[ __ ] but you're right man actually I
think let me give this guy a call right
now Michael and uh at least leave him a
voicemail
your call has been forwarded to an
automated voice-messaging system at the
tone please record your message when you
finished recording you may hang up or
press one for more options hey Michael
what's up man
this is Theo we spoke last week from the
podcast you had submitted a single mom
for San Francisco who was a real dragon
but I just wanted to call and apologize
you know I feel like I was you know I
was angry and and I think I took it out
on you and uh
because I couldn't get in touch with the
woman and and maybe it's for the best
maybe I'm glad I didn't get it you know
into an argument with her I mean I just
shouldn't have been taking action when I
was angry so I just want to say I
apologize and I hope you forgive me I'm
sorry and you know and I appreciate you
you know Karen enough to check out the
podcast and I know people can spend
their time and their efforts doing
anything and in the fact that you have
spent any of it listening to my
listening to me is a baffling and but
I'm grateful and and you cared enough to
submit somebody and I'm sorry that it
turned out the kind of the way that it
did but it certainly isn't your fault
and it's not my fault either and and and
we tried our best and uh yeah and that's
that and just you know if you check in
with her the single mother again just
tell her I'm sorry that you know we
couldn't make the evening something for
her that she could enjoy and I'm sorry
that uh that she thought that I was
racist and I think part of it was that
hurt my feelings but still no matter
what none of it I should have about
taking out on you so thankfully we were
able to find a a Mexican or Latino
mother single mom and gift that we were
going to give to your
and we were able to find a young lady
who's very deserving of it which you
know we called her at the end of the
episode the other day so I'm sorry that
your friend missed out on her gift and
you just let her know that I hope she
you know I hope she I hope she's feeling
better than she was whenever she came
out to dinner into the show and and
again I'm sorry man I'm sorry if I made
you feel uncomfortable
and and if I put you know if I called
him I didn't you know if I you know I
called him put it on the show and and
you know it kind of wasn't fair so thank
you very much for being somebody who
cared enough to to submit a single mom
and and in the future you know I hope to
be able to get you tickets or something
to a show and and I'll repay you talk
beeps always ruin my life but I think he
gets it I hope that left anyway Jesus
that was a long voicemail
that's I'm teddy I am chatty I guess huh
uh let's take another call man and thank
you to the caller for uh for bringing
that up because it was something that
was on my mind all right let's get into
another single call in just a second
I gotta let you know that when you're
selling online getting orders out can be
a real pain it is painful you know it's
painful to deal with the shipping and
get it all find the best way to ship and
what's you know what's gonna get it to
your customer but also get it there at a
rate that it works still so that you can
sell the product and make money yourself
you know looking for the best shipping
solution it's time-consuming so many
different carriers to choose from how do
you know you're making the best choice
that's why you need ship station comm
ship station comm it's the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders ship station
helps you get orders out quickly save
money on shipping costs and
keep your customers happy that's
important you want that you wanted to
get there and you want it to get to them
and them to be happy
no matter where you're selling Amazon
Etsy or your own website shipstation
brings all your orders in a one simple
interface no wonder ship station is the
number one choice of online sellers
you'll ship more in less time with the
best rates available it works with all
the major carriers USPS FedEx UPS even
Amazon Fulfillment and right now this
past weekend listeners can try ship
station for free for 60 days come home
oh that's a good deal
free for 60 days when you use promo code
t-h-e oh there's absolutely no risk you
can start your free trial without even
entering your credit card info just
visit ship station calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Theo
that's ship station Shi PSTA tion
dot-com then enter promo code theo
ship station comm make ship happen
support this past weekend and go check
it out oh let's take another call right
here what's up video game game this is
michael what up my goal and Michael is a
very very popular name who is Iman
somebody on Sunday night sorry Michael
very popular name now let's all word
calling you from sunny South Florida
Fort Lauderdale calling it down on the
Florida Keys a little place Kamal yeah
just to give a little comfort about the
single mom debacle you know they always
say no good deed goes unpunished but
don't let that break your spirit I think
people should just be nominating fans
and that leader was obviously not a fan
so there might be a little guideline to
implement second thing with a will the
bus Meister I think a lot of guys you
know they're in their own business and
got a little situation that premature
ejaculate the details to their lady so
that's why they end up riding it out and
maybe get themselves in a situation oh
oh well I didn't know that was something
that the that premature ejaculation or
that PE boy that pee you know that pre
EJ
I didn't know that a lot of guys if they
did it they was ashamed of it and then
stayed in there oh who is that who would
do that there that seems crazy mom if
you spill pudding in the kitchen dude
and it's all over the place
you don't just stay in there with it you
got to get out of the kitchen man you
got to you got to go tell somebody hey
hey hey hey yeah yeah just feel a bunch
of pudding in the kitchen you know I'm
saying you got a you gotta have a plan
you don't just pretend no Bonnie spilled
pudding in the kitchen
you got pudding all over your legs you
got put you got pudding on your cheeks
and you're gonna pretend that no Bonnie
spilled pudding in kitchen guy guy guy
guy um unbelievable as far as the single
mom I think look sick 14 out of 15
single moms have been awesome actually
about 13 or actually you know you know I
think some of its just expectations I
had some expectations you know we sent
uh you know it's like it's like yeah I
had expectations and so I shouldn't have
had them you know our my expectations
should have stopped if no one submitted
anybody that would maybe should be
something I could be bummed about but
you know Michael try to submit somebody
we did our best boom but yeah I think in
the future we'll just keep it as is and
we'll just do our best and you know we
should probably vet a little bit better
I think on our end
just make sure that the lady in some you
know kook but even thing you don't know
and at some point it's just out of our
control all we can do is try our best so
let's hear another call right here here
we go heroes is Mike Raleigh North
Carolina
Big Mike over there in Raleigh and
Raleigh Coleman was a UH
assistant principal at one of my schools
and he used to sleep in his car at lunch
and he would deny it but I saw him get
in there a couple time and kind of
closed the thing and he dressed in there
and he had a little thing he would tie
it off and just breathe out the UM about
a keyhole he would take the key piece
off and breathe through there put his
mouth about air on the inside and
breathe through it Aaron sometimes take
one of them little a sack milk in there
with him wandering him sack milks you
put that straw in and you just Dexter
that [ __ ] and then hit it
remember those but uh and he also was
some time where roller skates at lunch
and do a little athletics but go on home
word not really a hot topic grains and
starts kind of crazy story I'm going to
ever heard a surprise baby story but the
dam for the fourth of July we had a baby
boy and we had no idea that was coming
personal test back in November all came
back not pregnant she was having her
cycle or hit her every month
oh yeah that Tony Gwynn may be batting
for the
cycle bro it's like a brother gets loose
inside of your woman brought at Tony
Gwynn and they start acting wild you
know and they started just really just
just really acting wild he never kicked
one time and fourth of July she thought
she was constipated all day long I was
driving around going to go to a pool
party listen as the king in the sting
and you know she says she's got you're
intoxicated and feel good so we were
gonna go to the ER together and she
ended up going home going to sleep
I was waiting get that call she want to
go but I never got a call went by her
apartment car was gone
called the hospital said that were
getting uh she's been transported there
and came by a dad was outside waiting
for me say I was gonna be a daddy
she was in labor and I think it's funny
man you know some people in there when
they're pregnant give him all the shot
the paid tobin but the baby and the
woman was all this stuff my kid was
listening to this past weekend king of
sting and that congratulations by
Christie Leah no God sorry about that
part hope the kid will be okay homework
I just thought you think that cool man
maybe they'll grow up to be a comedian
one day that's off the a man gang gang
gang gang bruh he might be a comedian he
might also grow up you know to be a mime
I mean I do his must be hella quiet if
nobody even knew he was in their body
for nine months
think about it if I got something in my
body for nine months and it doesn't make
a peep that's not even a baby man I say
ninja your wife had a ninja so you might
want to give that thing a piece of cat
of you know a big piece of pound cake or
a big turkey leg or a cotton candy
because you got that low key that secret
Asian baby
that's a damn ninja dude if you didn't
dude I never go into the toilet and come
back a parent
nice Dark Arts brother you know and God
bless you guys with the new baby and I'm
so excited for you but I never you know
I never been over at you know at a
chick's house if she busts a fart or
something or a little bit of body gas
and next thing you know I'm a stepfather
so I don't know what's going on but
y'all might need to get on keto or y'all
might need to get on um you might need
to get a sonogram at the house brother
y'all you know what I'm saying you got
to know when you just got to know if
something's living inside of your body I
think I guess or maybe you don't you
know what actually bruh this sound great
you don't have to spend any money on the
baby shower you didn't have to paint the
room or do all of that dude if this baby
can be quiet for nine months inside of a
woman's body he can sleep in a garage he
could sleep in a [ __ ] in one of the
dEWALT's in the truck dude this bit you
could put this baby anywhere do you
could put this baby in a glove box baby
leave him in there overnight put a sack
milk in there with him like your boy
Raleigh Coleman so look man I think you
need to write a book on how to have that
$0 baby because you heard a million
dollar baby Hilary Swank but you never
heard of uh of uh of the of zero dollar
baby that's what you got to write how to
have a baby $0 zero sonograms no baby
clothes silent baby
baby you got to you got a damn mind
brother and congratulations man I'm
happy that your father and it sound like
your wife is doing okay and and you know
it sound like y'all beautiful over there
and and uh and thank you for sharing
that remarkable story that's remarkable
Jesus here we go let's take one more
call ninety five six six four nine five
zero three and you know Skillshare
you know and if you want to
support the podcast people are like man
I love the podcast how can I support go
try up try one of the deals get you to
blue shoes get you to hitters you know
start using shipstation quit doing all
this stuff yourself and not being able
to figure it out or go to Skillshare
dot-com slash theof on Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
and creators man they're people that are
making something you know just like in
our Bishop Gunn they say I'm making it
that's who that's creators man
and you might be making something maybe
this guy's suddenly he's making that
book he's gonna make this zero dollar
baby how to do it how to you know have a
baby inside of your wife and not tell
anybody I mean now that's the move the
other guy called in and said look if you
you know if you spill pudding in the
kitchen you got to tell them maybe this
guy tells you where to put the pudding
so nobody even knows they got a dessert
milling around in them but Skillshare is
an online learning community with more
than 25,000 classes and design business
and more you'll discover countless ways
to fuel your creativity and your career
you know people always want to learn how
I gotta go back to college I gotta go
you know I want to learn about trains I
got to go be a hobo for two years no you
don't Daniel no you don't all you got to
do is take some classes social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing whether you're looking to
develop a new passion or start a side
hustle or gain professional skills
skills share is there to keep you
learning thriving and reaching those
goals you want to learn graphic design
yes you do we all do graphic design
basics core principles for visual design
that's easy
next thing you know you learn it next
thing you know you go to a company in
your town you say hey what you're
missing is your graphic design elements
they're not there you you charge them a
fee boom you hit them with a couple of
deals Gang Gang son now you're a graphic
designer that's your business you don't
need to go rent
big office and do all of the [ __ ] in
a 1996 daddy join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for our
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's two months you could be
a graphic designer Bunyan
that's right Skillshare is offering this
past weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free to sign up go to Skillshare
dot-com slash Theo von again go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von to start
your two months now as Skillshare comm
slash Theo von and I'm grateful to our
advertisers for uh for supporting this
past weekend wow you got a new baby what
man a lot going on you know we apologize
to Michael we got um we got school
starting back we're living life we're
living life man and thank you guys for
reminding me that I am cuz I walked in
here today and I was just you know I
wasn't remembering that and that's why
I'm grateful you guys are here to remind
me of you know that good things are
going on and if there I finally feel
like they're going on in my life if
they're going on in yours and you tell
me about them then they are going on in
mine too Gang Gang let's take this call
hey Theo is staring from Omaha and I
just wanted to maybe ask the listeners
for some advice 34 years old this
December and just seems like a really
[ __ ] up life and it doesn't really
seem for the obvious reasons I went to
school got a undergraduate degree in a
master's degree and don't have a
criminal record still because of student
loans and whatnot living with the
parents and real hard to beat a lady
because of having to have a mountain
worth of student loan debt and I just oh
yeah it's hard to [ __ ] it at your
parents behind a bunch of debt that's
hard to do no lady is like hey yeah
let's go over to your parents and [ __ ]
behind all your bills that's tough
homeward figured when I was younger the
life be better especially if I walk the
straight and narrow I did have a lot of
fun but just seems like life isn't
really adding up to being what I
expected it to be so there's anyone else
out there who's in their 20s and 30s is
suffering with a mountain of student
loan debt maybe they have some advice on
how they're getting through just paying
off bills like I can as fast as I can
but thanks thank you for calling man and
I'm sorry that you're dealing with that
struggle and um and this call actually
came in I'm reading this note here it
says this call came in a week a week
back and then we got another call from
him but I want to say this about student
loan debt get consolidation check out
different companies and pay a lower rate
over a longer time pay it for the rest
of your life who cares so many people
are here or this isn't what I think this
may be not what you think so you don't
have to listen right now but just pay it
who cares if you have to pay it for 50
years who gives a damn pay it $50 or
$100 200 for 50 years [ __ ] pay it oh
well just pay it so many people like I
got a do [ __ ] that spend the rest of
your money and join your life living
your life pay that little bit by little
bit overtime who knows elections in
eight years or whatever they may [ __ ]
they may bankrupt the whole nation by
paying your student loan debt so then
nobody has student loans but everybody's
just out on the street you know and it's
war and it's total war because there's
no cuz nothing means anything I don't
know man we'll see but I'll just say
this man don't beat yourself up over
that and student loan debt isn't that
much you know in the big amount it is
but in a small monthly amount it isn't
and we can pay that so you just got to
work a little bit harder man you know
there's been times where I was making
nothing but I've you know we can pay
that it's not that insane
and you know sorry man I got a little
I'm [ __ ] I'm telling you man just
been kind of jazzed out
I've been jazzed out man like I got damn
wynton marsalis in me let's take another
call hey hey Theo its Darren from Omaha
Nebraska and I'm really actually okay
and this is Darren again called um a
week later this is a fresh call to
thankful you haven't had a chance to
play my other message like yet
I was really beating myself up in our
last one and this last episode from July
29 it really helped out I mean honestly
when I started focusing on the fact that
I you know in the gym five days a week
making my fat ask you know go there and
also have a full-time job and also
taking care of other people and trying
to make other people's lives better by
being a good human being I have a lot
going for me and you know my situation
will eventually change and I really
appreciate that last episode focusing on
action because I think things are going
to get better just a matter of time
thanks again gang bruh Wow yeah man
that's amazing man a week you know the
perspective change you say you've been
going to the gym getting your blood
flowing every time that is the solution
for me every time if my brain is leaking
bruh then I got to get my pores to start
leaking I got to get sweat activity they
call that sweat activity because once my
body starts feeling good I feel like I
can do anything you know by nature we're
supposed to be in motion by nature we
are supposed to be in motion the world
is round according to most people and
you know you're not supposed to be
sedentary on a round object if you see a
seal on a ball they moving they're
moving to keep their balance they're
moving if you see a seal on a block
they're doing nuttin you know they're
doing cigarettes they're doing putting
packs they're doing pop-tarts with the
icing on them and I like the ones
without icing
but um one amount but what I'm saying is
we're supposed to be emotion we've built
this world now in this society
especially in America here where we're
really sedentary like I'm sitting here
in a damn desk now in a room that's in
I'm in a room that's inside of another
room that's inside of a building I'm
three rooms deep right now I'm so
disconnected from activity at this
moment so we got to go out and get it
you know our bodies were meant to be
really like oceans there's but they're
supposed to move and flow and get the
vibe you got to get that vibe so if I'm
not here with no vibe doing nothing
doing hostas cakes and you know just
being a down snack I dactyl and [ __ ]
smoking you know freebase and Fritos
then yeah I'm gonna be nothing bro I'm
gonna be slow or I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be looking at all the doldrums but yeah
we can stay busy and yeah and I
appreciate you reminding me man cuz I
need to hear it it's just a boomerang we
made here I say something then y'all say
something and we go back and forth man
and we stay alive bro I love that let's
take another call here nine eighty five
six six four nine five zero three and go
attack that student debt man look at it
that as a challenge you alright
government you want to put student debt
on me goal if do get your life get your
life you can do it man you're capable
guy you sound capable you could do
whatever but this is our life we have to
do it now gang boy yo what's going on
man this is mark from Pittsburgh little
north of Pittsburgh Butler PA out of
Butler PA man in Pittsburgh everybody
knows a couple ladies came down from
West Virginia once and they try to give
me a little sex out there but a parking
garage down there down there in uh by
Union Station or whatever and uh
and I got a little bit of it you know
and there was aunt and niece and they
said they wanted it was from Wheeling
West Virginia they said they came to
give me some of that Wheeling feeling
and I got a little bit of it and it was
okay I would say probably it was alright
and one it wasn't crazy but it wasn't it
wasn't two - it was alright
Owen and I was listening to your podcast
talking to fish of gun about how they
were in that out Rolling Stones header
you know it's 20 day they you guys
talked about fans of the podcast these
fans officious gun because my fiancé and
I are huge fans of the podcast and we
have become huge fans of Bishop gun as
well
they're so good man dude I'll be honest
with you when I first heard them I
didn't even think they were any good bro
but the more I heard them I think they
are good and then I think they're really
good gang bro and we're going to be
getting married this August August tends
to be precise and after we say I do
shine is going to be playing by Bishop
gun when we walk it down the aisle
and and that's just and that's just
because your podcast when we hear that
we know you know we're about to get in a
good mood and we just want to get sent
off right and a song that puts us in the
right Bob in the right spirit so thank
you for everything you do thank you for
everybody you help and yeah Gang Gang
Gang man thank you dude I appreciate
that message man you know that really
lifted my spirits maybe you just put me
in up in a nice place just now you know
you put something in me that feels good
and I think it's just
you came with the positivity you know
you came with the care you know you got
the wife you got a special moment
you know you related it to us and
everybody listens and pays attention to
this deal and you made us feel like we
have some value a little bit or that's
what I felt and so thank you very much
man we're happy to be part of your
wedding man that shine maybe it does
make me feel good you know what I'm
gonna get out of here on it right now I
think um I'm gonna get out of here on
some shine and yeah I got to stay in the
light cuz that's the only way we win it
does it the other side is just there's
no end to it
the judgment my look man you know like
nothing on the outside is gonna change
the way I feel
is set for me and the way I interact
with the world if everything is if
something's always wrong then
something's wrong with me and it doesn't
make me a bad person if something's
wrong with me
it doesn't make me a bad person if I
have a bad day you know it doesn't make
me a bad person
you know I just but I got to right the
ship I don't stay alone I communicate
with others a lot of it I do right here
talking with you guys listening to
people talk the guy is the baby you know
they think it's a little you know a bit
a fart or something or a belts imagine
that dude I'd be afraid to Pat my wife
on the back after that she'll burp up us
you know a damn stroller with twins in
it man oh man but you know I'm glad you
got a lady and I'm glad you're gonna be
coming down the aisle that's what maybe
that's what it did just picturing two
people coming down to the aisle to a
song that I know makes me feel good so I
know it makes you feel good and man I
could just relate that music and it's
funny what music does when it gets in us
it's funny how he can do something
special to us
music it's interesting it's like a
little baby you know it's that [ __ ]
it's that air ninja it really is man I'm
gonna take us out of here on that man
I'm gonna take us out of here with a
little bit of shine Michael again I'm
sorry if I put you on blast last week I
could have done better I'm not really
sorry if I'm still angry at that lady a
little bit I'm not really angry at her
actually I'm more grateful that we found
a young lady you know who was excited
about us and uh hey man whatever it's
all good did everything will be okay you
know I need to expect less and do more
and show up with a positive attitude and
man we're pretty lucky aren't we guys we
are pretty lucky thank you guys for
being here this weekend
what else any other news I got to share
with you maybe some things but I'm
waiting till next week when I'll have
more information but you guys be good to
yourselves man let's take it out of here
with a little bit of Bishop and yeah
[Music]
do you say I do yes
do you see I do you may now kiss the
bride
I'm just sitting on your front porch
children how could I be so far from mine
[Music]
and my mom is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll catch up where you'll spin
[Music]
now I'm just floating on the breeze and
that beautiful enlightening leads I must
be honest
when I reach that I'll share this piece
of my thought it's gonna take
little town
for me to sell that pocket brave
[Music]
do
congratulations on their wedding man
check your wife check your spouse for
babies everybody check your lady for a
damn baby that ain't a mole that might
be a baby
[Music]
come on now and find a song
you know let's go all the way
[Music]
just before you
till death do y'all part man I wish you
a million happy years together and yeah
be good to each other huh and be good to
yourself mean you deserve it and thank
you for you guys for reminding me to do
the same gang
you